the God of War franchise has a sprawling
timeline that interweaves its great
Greek tragedy across nine games and two
wildly distinct mythologies and while
I'd love to say it's a relatively simple
chronology to untangle the point is it's
not hence why I'm making this video and
with God of War Ragnarok set to further
Slide the franchise's anti-hero Kratos
into the mythological Maya what better
time to dive back into the ghost of
Sparta's Saga of Gods and Monsters hey
my name's Adam this is my big old Board
of gods and Titans that likely won't see
the end of this video and this is the
God of War timeline fully explained
foreign
[Music]
kicks off with a healthy stab of
backstory courtesy of the monochrome
flashbacks from God of War ghost of
Sparta here we catch up with Kratos
spending some quality time with the
family and back in the day that meant
kicking the Everlasting crap out your
brother side note watching this back you
might assume that this fella here is
Kratos because of well the distinctive
red markings but you would be wrong dear
viewer this lad here is damos kratos's
brother and perhaps the main catalyst
for our anti-heroes violent journey
through Greek and Norse mythology you
see these flashbacks showcase the two
brothers training to become Spartan
warriors only their sparring is cut
short by the untimely arrival of a pair
of Greek gods Ares the god of war and
Athena the god of wisdom they're here in
Olympus business taking care of a little
prophecy that predicts the downfall of
Zeus and Co turns out that the end of
the Greek gods will come at the hands of
a marked mortal and Aries in Athena zero
in on damos and his distinctive
birthmarks they nabbed the tiny Spartan
lad and begin to make their exit only
for our good power Kratos to stand in
their way for his insolence Ares
straight up sucker punches him in the
face leaving a nasty scar over his eye
and if it weren't for the mercy of
Athena Ares would have killed Kratos
right there and then a decision that
ironically seals the god of War's fate
later on and in his brother's honor
Kratos tattoos himself in the image of
his brother's scars which you know might
just mean that prophecy is back on the
guards
through flashbacks interwoven into the
story of the original God of War we
learned that Kratos becomes a captain in
the Spartan Army in charge of a horde of
rampaging murderous soldiers and Kratos
himself has become something of a
bloodthirsty power-hungry warlord ever
pushing to extend the boundaries of the
Spartan Empire to the disdain of his
family Kratos pursues his bloodlust
until he meets his match in the form of
a mammoth Barbarian Army he blindly
charges right on Into The Fray and to be
honest it doesn't go all that well
facing certain defeat he calls upon the
God of War Ares must have forgotten that
encounter with his brother eh to help
him defeat his enemies and push for
victory Ares being the self-serving
bastard that he is agrees on the
condition that Kratos swear loyalty to
him and Kratos caught in an extremely
desperate moment signed on the
metaphorical dotted line and the deal is
sealed as the iconic Blades of chaos are
chained to Kratos his arms once attached
the chains remained so Chained and
seared to the flesh a part of the
bearer's body permanent reminder of
kratos's pledge and from that moment on
Kratos wages war on behalf of Ares
striking down all foes in his path at
the whim of the God of War this
Relentless Warpath eventually leads him
to a village occupied by worshipers of
Athena Kratos hacks and slashes his way
through the villages blindly murdering
them left right and center but
unbeknownst to Kratos is the fact that
Ares has led the Spartan Captain right
into a trap in his blind Rampage Kratos
kills his own wife and daughter and in
that horrific moment he snaps out of his
bloodthirsty Rampage the image of his
two final victims would stay with him
for all his days Ares believes that this
key act would turn Kratos into the
perfect Warrior but instead Kratos
renounces Ares and vows to get revenge
on the God of War as he Mourns his wife
and child the Oracle of the destroyed
Village curses Kratos and fuses the
ashes of his dead family to his body
turning his skin pale white and branding
him as the ghost of Sparta damn this
French is cold
[Music]
with his oath to Aries broken Kratos
becomes a Marked Man in more ways than
one God of War ascension sees our
tormented Spartan hunted down by the
three Furies for breaking his oath to a
god this ancient retelling of classic
90s action of The Fugitive which is
possibly a connection I've made just
because I've watched that recently sees
Kratos team up with a man named orcos
who we learn as the son of Ares and
electo one of the furies far from the
perfect Warrior Ares was hoping for
orcos is cast aside and takes up the
role of the Fury's oath keeper while the
main narrative is quite slight and
really just a warm-up for the inevitable
Kratos versus the furies fight we do
learn a few new facts about kratos's
bond to Aries for starters Ascension
reveals the reason behind ares's desire
to control Kratos Ares molded you to
take down the very walls of Olympus you
see it turns out that Zeus has forbidden
the gods from Waging War on one another
and as a result this rule bars air
series from seizing power on Mount
Olympus ares's way of getting around
this is to groom the ultimate warrior
with three tests that would bind said
Warrior to his demands and one of these
tests turned out to be kratos's
unwitting murder of his family either
way back to God of War ascension's main
plot long story short Kratos kills the
furies
[Applause]
you were expecting more
um well poor old orcos also doesn't make
it past the credits of Ascension The
Unlucky lad is still the Fury's oath
keeper including Kratos is it out to
Ares and with him still alive Kratos
will never be able to take revenge on
the God of War orkos literally begs for
death from Kratos claiming it will bring
them both released from the tyranny of
Ares Kratos reluctantly obliges and puts
the oath keeper out of his misery thus
setting in motion his path towards
Redemption with the death of orcos the
Blood Oath to Aries was finally broken
[Music]
while his bond to Aries might have been
broken Kratos is still very much in debt
to the rest of the Gods and that's where
we catch up with him in the PSP
Adventure chains of Olympus about five
years into his servitude Kratos is
kicking up a storm in the city of Attica
where he offspoke the Persian king
and a big [ __ ] off basilisk
as he's starting to feel too old for all
this God shite Kratos spies the sun
Vanishing from the sky leaving the world
in total darkness not content was simply
calling this nighttime Kratos
investigates and discovers that Helios
the god of the sun has been kidnapped
allowing his sneaky colleague Morpheus
the god of dreams to slide on into
Olympus and put the gods into a deep
cozy sleep Kratos traces the whereabouts
of Helios to the underworld by using his
steeds the horses that carry the sun
Chariot across the sky down in the
Underworld Kratos discovers that the
Titan Atlas has escaped from his chains
which is odd because he's bloody massive
but even more intriguing for Kratos is
that he encounters visions of his
daughter Calliope naturally this vision
is too good to be true and is a test of
kratos's will created by Persephone
goddess of the underworld and embittered
wife of Hades Kratos once again Falls
right into the Trap and is reunited with
his daughter on the fields of Elysium
my child
[Music]
why did you go I am here now child
and it's here where surprise surprise
Persephone reveals that it was her plan
to kidnap Helios alongside the escaped
Atlas in a bid to get back at the gods
for trapping her down in the Land of the
Dead Kratos then coldly turns his back
on his daughter in surely one of the
most bizarre uses of a QuickTime event
in all of gaming hello please all in
service of his pursuit of the goddess of
the underworld Kratos eventually catches
up to Persephone brutally murdering her
and putting a stop to her plans to seize
power in Olympus which has already
establishing itself as a solid motive
for this franchise's antagonists which
marks the first time I get to use this
flashy board
good riddance he then escapes the
underworld aboard helios's seeds and
absolutely exhausted from the efforts of
his adventures in the Land of the Dead
Falls from The Chariot he's rescued from
certain death by the reawakened gods
Athena and Helios who leave him dozing
on a Cliffside overlooking the Aegean
Sea
[Music]
all of which finally lands us at the
very first God of War Game set a decade
into kratos's servitude to the gods of
Olympus the original God of War kicks
off in suitably Epic fashion
actually
absolutely exhausted at the
relentlessness of his deeds across the
last decade Kratos seeks out Athena in
search of a get out clause from his
service to the gods the goddess of
wisdom points him in the direction of
Athens where he's finally tasked with
defeating Ares Kratos arrives at Athens
and meets the Oracle who vows to help
Kratos defeat the rampaging God of War
by pointing him towards the one ancient
MacGuffin that will actually help defeat
a god Pandora's Box Kratos learns from
Athena that the Box can be found in the
temple of Pandora which naturally is
located in one of the most ridiculously
isolated spots you can find Atop The
Titan Chronos who is cursed to wander a
desert for eternity Kratos not one to
back down to an insurmountable challenge
Ventures to the temple Which is far from
the cheeriest place in ancient Greece
and becomes the first mortal to ever
reach Pandora's Box so you think you can
conquer the Temple of the gods do you
it's never been done you know a fact
that Aries seemingly Clues into the
moment it happens and from right bang in
the middle of the destruction he's
wreaking in Athens Aries loves a
javelin-shaped column all the way to
wherever the hell the Temple of Pandora
is and scores a bullseye right in the
middle of kratos's chest I mean you
gotta respect that coordination a
platoon of Harpy's turn up and escort
the box back to Aries while Kratos
slowly bleeds out in the company of the
memories of his wretched life and so
Kratos dies instead of bringing this
timeline to a close however the ghost of
Sparta plunges deep down into the
underworld yet again but this time he's
meant to be there his trip is incredibly
brief he literally climbs his way out on
a handy rope that appears before his
eyes courtesy of a mysterious
Gravedigger back in Athens as that's how
death Works in this fantasy version of
ancient Greece I guess anyway for the
convenience of the story Kratos is
exactly back where he needs to be he
finds Ares screaming at the sky cursing
Zeus for his part in creating Kratos so
and for this insolence Sue Skiffs Kratos
with a timely Thunderbolt which he
flings right at the God of War making
him drop Pandora's Box and when opened
aside from containing all the horrible
[ __ ] like plagues and death that Miss
Telus were in the box Kratos simply
turns into a giant version of himself so
he could go Mano Amano with Ares and not
want to be outdone Ares turned into a
spider
um okay uh after Aries torches Kratos
with more visions of his dead wife and
child the game turns into a full-on
side-on fighting game complete with
health bars and everything it's awesome
Kratos eventually wins the fight and
sends a giant sword right through the
God of War which means I can Mark you
off OG God of War
so Aries dies and blows up like an
ancient Greek nuke which rids Kratos of
his Nemesis but not of the horrible
memories plaguing his mind despite his
deeds the God's white Kratos a sinful
slate clean but leave him with his
nightmares at his Wit's End Kratos seeks
release by fleeing himself from atop a
cliff overlooking the Aegean but the
gods even interfere in this act instead
raising him up to Olympus itself to take
the vacant seat as the God of War
[Music]
right we're back at the present timeline
parts of ghost of Sparta where she's the
new God of War wrapped with visions of
his long dead family also he thought on
the whim of a vision about his dead
mother Kratos travels to the Temple of
Poseidon in the mythical city of
Atlantis fights off a giant sea monster
has a reunion with his dear old mum and
learns that his brother damos is still
alive and that's all within the first
hour of the game and [ __ ] just gets
weirder as his mum is about to tell
Kratos who his dad is no Jerry Springer
DNA tests here Lads she turns into a
hideous monster and Kratos has to kill
her
on his way to find his brother Kratos
kills Uranus the daughter of death
disembowels a giant lion and fights
himself as a kid as you do and we're
still only halfway through this mad game
this is all before he encounters and
subsequently murders Midas yep the man
and for all these trials and
tribulations it turns out that Kratos
has to trudge all the way back to
Atlantis to find his brother ah video
games never change Kratos travels to the
domain of death and finally discovers
his brother chained up naturally damos
is pretty pissed at being left for dead
by Kratos and he nearly beats the ghost
of Sparta to within an inch of his life
get up
me before he's carried off by the
personification of death Thanatos who's
rightly pretty pissed off himself that
Kratos killed his daughter long story
short Kratos saves his brother from
falling into the depths of hell and the
Spartan Brothers team up to literally
kill death because if he can why not
damos doesn't make it through the fight
though and after burying his brother's
body Kratos departs through the gates of
Olympus
next up on our timeline is the mobile
game God of War betrayal remember that
one because I sure as hell didn't either
way betrayal sees Kratos turning his
back on the gods and helping the
Spartans to wage war across Greece and
naturally for a 15 year old mobile game
there's not a whole deal of meaningful
narrative content you see Kratos goes
from screen left to screen right hacking
and slashing to his heart's content
until Zeus goes hang on land all this
death and destructions of it much and
when Zeus tells you that you know you've
gone too far
as the franchise's first true sequel
kicks into gear Kratos is in full God of
War mode rampaging around roads like he
owns the place he doesn't for this mild
indiscretion he's stripped of his Godly
Powers by Athena the god that helped him
get set up an Olympus in the first place
as is always the case with the Greek
deities the gods don't always see eye to
eye hence why Zeus gives Kratos with a
Blade of Olympus to rectify Athena's
mistake Kratos the stubborn fool that he
is looks this gift horse in the mouth
and declines so Zeus kills him
here this is what the second maybe third
time he's died I'm beginning to lose
count he is rescued by the physical
embodiment of the Titan Gaia put simply
the Greek Mother Earth and she vows to a
Kratos in seeking revenge on Zeus by
helping him change his fate her plan to
do this have Kratos visit the actual
literal Fates and convince them to
change reality the winged horse Pegasus
turns up for narrative convenience and
whisks Kratos away to the land of the
Titans where Kratos bumps into
Prometheus the lad who was punished by
Zeus for giving fire to mankind Kratos
puts the poor Titan out of his misery
and this act of Mercy imbues him with
the power of the Titans somehow he is
ashes will give you great strength
Kratos take them within you and lose the
strength to defeat for enemies Pegasus
swings on by to continue kratos's tour
of Greek mythology next stop the island
of creation the home of the sisters of
Fate there Atop The steeds of time yeah
everything sounds epic in God of War he
encounters the legendary hero Theseus
who he promptly kills
because that's the established formula
for these games at this point on his way
to the fates Kratos meets friends old
and new namely the resurrected Barbarian
King and Perseus both of whom die
then he uses the wings of Icarus who
also dies just FYI
to fly the last distance to the sisters
only to end up in the depths of Hell
chatting to the Titan Atlas who regales
Kratos with the story of the Great War
Between the gods and the Titans after
that quick history lesson Atlas
eventually deposits Kratos exactly where
he needs to be on his continued quest to
seek out the fates Kratos learns about
Zeus's sacking of Sparta tussles with
the actual Kraken and flies of Phoenix
right into the Fate's penthouse suite
and naturally he doesn't just have a
polite chat with the Fate he fights them
this leads to a scene with some pretty
neat Back to the Future Part 2 Vibes
where Kratos has to make sure the events
at the end of the original God of War
take place before he yeah you guessed it
kills the Fates
[Music]
foreign Kratos finds his thread of
Destiny and is able to travel back in
time to the pivotal moment where Zeus
killed him thus changing his fate just
as he's about to kill Zeus Athena
intervenes and gets stabbed instead and
now I can cross you off
the story comes to a close with Kratos
traveling back in time to the great war
between gods and Titans and recruiting
Gaia and Co to take the fight to Olympus
and the game then ends on a right proper
Cliffhanger with the Titans arriving at
the gates of Olympus ready for round two
Zeus your son has returned I bring
Olympus
and it's that Cliffhanger that God of
War 3's magnificently epic opening pays
off and then some it's a full-on Clash
of the Titans as the gods of Olympus
defend their territory from their
predecessors and the first key battle is
land versus water as Poseidon god of the
oceans takes on Gaia Kratos caught in
the middle of it all notches up Poseidon
as the first casualty among the gods by
just
um well
gosh this is just the beginning of the
Carnage in this game
smelling Victory Kratos and Gaia go for
the head of the snake Zeus only for the
head honcho to Smite them all the way
back down Mount Olympus sending Kratos
right to the realm of Hades there Kratos
bumps into a now Immortal Athena now
living life in some higher existence her
words not mine and she directs Kratos to
seek out the flame of Olympus to help
bring about the destruction of Zeus
while in the realm of the Dead Kratos
drops in on a couple more Gods
Hephaestus the god of fire and forges
and Hades the god of the underworld
himself who Kratos kills just for
Giggles I guess at this point by ripping
his soul right out of his body
foreign
[Music]
hades's death naturally brings about the
total collapse of the underworld and
Kratos escapes topside to the City of
Olympia where he re-enters The Fray
aiding in the takedown of Helios god of
the sun
yeah that would be much
the rest of the game takes place at
night then
as he continues on his quest to find the
flame Kratos happens across the
wisecracking Hermes the messenger of the
Gods who just does not stop talking
kill any family members lately after
discovering that his part of success
once again lies with Pandora's Box
Kratos shuts up Hermes once and for all
by dismembering his legs and nicking his
Speedy sandals
Kratos then plays an ancient Greek
version of Guitar Hero to access the
flame of Olympus and that's a sentence I
never thought I'd say out loud
[Music]
as he continues to search for Pandora
Kratos comes across Hera the goddess of
women marriage infertility and
long-suffering wife of Zeus who pits
Kratos against his half-brother Hercules
who's naturally a bit hurt at not being
Zeus's favorite this mad soap opera ends
the only way it ever was going to with
Hercules pummeled into a bloody pulp
from here Kratos travels back to her
feistus to seek help in finding his
daughter Pandora in daedalus's Labyrinth
her Feist agrees to help Kratos and send
him off to find a precious stone with
which to forge a worthy weapon this
results in craters coming face to face
with the Titan Cronus once again which
doesn't end well for Kronos thank you
or her Feist as it seems
as Kratos can clearly smell [ __ ] and
doesn't take Kylie to being sent on
suicide missions by giant Gods time to
cross both of them off the board gosh we
are running out of gods no way add one
more
right let's just take stock of where
we're at because I think most everybody
is dead except for yeah Zeus and Gaia
so Kratos finds Pandora they open the
box which sacrifices the poor lass and
things come to her head with a climactic
battle atop Mount Olympus where Kratos
and Gaia fight Zeus to the death which
results in Gaia getting stabbed in the
heart and Zeus literally getting melee
to death and a hideous first person view
where the screen literally just gets
covered in blood and with that my Greek
Board of gods and Titans is complete and
God of War 3 ends with Kratos looking
out over the chaos he has wrought across
the Grecian lands and with the not
Athena begging for his power Kratos
finally ends his suffering by impaling
himself on the Blade of Olympus
oh
my God
only we're not at the end of this mad
mythological tragedy just yet as is
teasing a very ambiguous sting at the
end of the credits a teaser that wasn't
fulfilled for nearly a decade with the
release of
[Music]
yes with the old and in with the North
I'm gonna need a new board so it turns
out kratos's destruction of the Greek
world was localized hence why there's
still life here in the freezing North
where a seemingly Immortal God of War
has settled a century has passed since
kratos's war in Olympus and the Ghost of
Sparta has seemingly mellowed a tad he
has settled down in the realm of midgard
and has married a woman called Faye and
together they have a son called atreus a
son who has no clue who or what his
father really is
but as this is God of War this happy
life is not to last long as the 2018
flavor of God of War opens with Kratos
cremating the body of his wife before
being thrown into An Almighty battle
with a stranger that has suspiciously
Godlike powers
after seemingly winning this
earth-shattering battle Kratos and
atreus vowed to scatter FaZe ashes at
the top of the highest peak in the nine
Realms and from an incredibly simplistic
perspective that's basically the entire
plot of the game but obviously a lot
more actually happens amidst this Father
and Son pilgrimage first off there's the
mysterious Witch of the woods who AIDS
them on their journey and Kratos
immediately cottoned onto the fact that
there's something Godly about her then
there's this absolute mad lad mirmir who
helps the pair get ahead in the game I'm
so sorry he instructs the pair that the
highest peak is actually located in
johannine and then asks Kratos to behead
him and take his head to be resurrected
by The Witch of the Woods yeah oh I
can't watch this
once revived he reveals that the witch
is actually the goddess Freya wife to
Odin and mother to thaw Boulder Etc they
have a lot of kids while he's incredibly
reluctant to trust her Kratos allows
Freya to Aid them in their Quest and as
they continue on their merry way to
yotenheim the father-son relationship is
tested to the absolute limits atreus
showing flashes of his father's rage in
a way that scares even Kratos finally
learns his dad's true identity and even
the true identity of his mum Fey too who
it turns out is actually a giant from
yonheim meaning that the little ads DNA
makeup is the unique mix of half giant
quarter God and quarter mortal oh and
the slightly confusing fact that these
mom and the Giants referred to him as
Loki yep more on that in the next game
the mysterious stranger from the opening
is also revealed to be the god Boulder
and as previously mentioned the son of
Freya attempting to break the cycle of
violence perpetrated by balder who is
intent on murdering his mother Kratos
steps in and snaps balda's neck Freya
who is ready to die at the hands of a
petulant Sun then vows revenge on Kratos
for murdering boulder oh hey that's
another God to take off my new board
bye-bye border all of that brings us to
the conclusion of the game that sees
Kratos and atreus finally make it to the
tallest peak in the nine Realms and
Scatter phase ashes
[Music]
and with that I guess the pair can
finally get some peace and quiet well no
upon their return to midgard Mimi
informs them that the three-year-long
thimble winter has begun which
eventually leads to a little something
called Ragnarok the literal end of the
Norse world oh
[Music]
yeah here we go again not a lot is known
just yet about The Narrative of God of
War Ragnarok but the key fact that we do
know is that it takes place three years
later at the tail end of thimblewinter
meaning that Ragnarok is right around
the corner hence the title I guess the
game's story will focus on Kratos and
atreus's attempts to prevent Ragnarok
while also searching for answers as to
why atres was referred to as Loki by the
Giants of yotenheim oh and there's also
the small matter of the introduction of
Thor the God of Thunder and the
reintroduction of Freya both of which
are out for revenge on Kratos for
various reasons and I'm sure I'll be I
can a few more Gods off my big old board
so look forward to that I guess
and that Pals is the God of War timeline
fully explained I'll be doing a deeper
dive into the story of the 2018 God of
War in a future video so if you want to
refresh it before going into Ragnarok
make sure to subscribe for that thanks a
lot for watching guys I'll see you next
time
[Music]